der rauch es nicht mehr zu sehen über
den türmen von rotterdam
aber das chaos hier an der hilde la cité
im herzen von paris hält an
viele leute wollen hinüber
und dürfen nur wenn sie an den ostkreis
zu verarbeiten können
weil die im krankenhaus arbeiten oder
der von der hitze im juli aus den
kleineren der beiden inseln sieht man
die zerstörung aus dessen de la cité mit
notre dame steht noch
cölbe steht noch die wände stehen noch
die kirmes gehen aber das tun ist
die feuerwehrleute arbeiten weiter an
wenn man genau hinschaut im turm
dort einige feuerwehrleute gegen und
gleich zum bausachverständige
und die struktur des gebäudes
viele menschen nahmen schon spenden
zugesagt
wenn dazu in der nacht gesagt dass
wieder aufgebaut wird und das macht den
menschen
hoffnung